es Shangai y los manifestantes gritan
contra los confinamientos y contra el
presidente
la policía responde con detenciones y lo
que empezó el sábado como una vigilia
por los muertos en un incendio en un
edificio en la región de singyang se
convirtió en protestas contra las
estrictas restricciones por Kobe 19
creo que primero es
por siguiente
terminar con su dictadura porque a él
solo le importa el mismo es por eso que
mucha gente murió por él pero ahora es
una buena noticia que muchas personas se
den cuenta que es un presidente ilegal
en el incendio murieron 10 personas Se
presume que no pudieron abandonar el
edificio por las restricciones por Kobe
19 esto en una región de mayoría oigur
es decir musulmana contra la que hay
denuncia de vulneración de los Derechos
Humanos familiares denuncian que la
asistencia llegó demasiado tarde
siempre están siendo perseguidos por el
gobierno chino de una forma u otra y
odio eso
las protestas se van expandiendo por
todo el país un fenómeno poco común en
China esto es Beijing en la prestigiosa
universidad singua los estudiantes
cantaron proclamas por un estado de
derecho democrático y por la libertad de
expresión son las consecuencias del
hartazgo después de casi tres años de
confinamientos en China por el covid 19
que co con los días en los que el país
está registrando el mayor número de
casos desde el inicio de la pandemia